House of the Dragons King viserys played
by Patty considine is a sympathetic man
who might not be as well suited to rule
as his grandfather King jahiris he often
looks weary and retains painful
lacerations from the Iron Throne that
don't heal the shows for saris as middle
aged and of average height and build he
wears his silvery hair long and keeps a
scruffy beard he wears a crown of gold
and silver embossed with a Targaryen
Crest and he seems to only dress up for
four more occasions the viserys
described him Fire and Blood as a
returned Jolly King when he ascended to
the throne he chose to wear jeheris's
Gold Crown beset with colorful gemstones
book for Sarah sported a bushy mustache
and started out pleasantly plump not
unlike King Robert Baratheon from Game
of Thrones season 1 the series continued
to gain weight throughout his Reign
though well liked by his people over
indulgence calls for CRS to suffer from
gout chest pain and other health
problems that played him for the rest of
his life George RR Martin describes him
as extremely fat redder face and unable
to climb stairs